Trans Air 275, active runway 14, winds calm, altimeter 2993.
Roger, Trans Air 275, we are two miles on final for 14.
It's not only aircraft that can wander onto an active runway.
Our Truck 20 leaving garage for Air Eastern hangar.
Truck 20, proceed via Bravo, Charlie, Echo.
Hold short of runway 14, traffic on final.
Roger.
Bravo, Echo, Charlie, hold short of 14; truck 20.
Truck 20, that's CHARLIE ECHO.
Roger.
The driver of this truck...
...doesn't understand the directions he's been given by the Flight Service Specialist.
He thinks he'll annoy him by asking for clarification.
The Flight Service Specialist hears the uncertainty in the driver's messages,...
...but he assumes the driver is fully aware...
...he's approaching the active runway,...
...and that there is an aircraft on final.
Preoccupied with finding his way,...
...the vehicle operator rolls through the hold line at runway one-four...
Truck 20, get off the runway.
Now!
This time, the Flight Service Specialist noticed the truck approaching the runway,...
...but it could be a different story at night or in poor visibility.